les Chéries Enrico Matias s'excuse après
avoir voulu dégommer physiquement la
France insoumise comprenez-vous les
réactions on va voir déjà tout de suite
c'était hier chez Pascal chez Pascal pro
Enrico mas était sur C news regardez
quand j'entends l'extrême gauche H qui
se défosse devant cette horreur et ben
vous m'obligez à dire ce que je voulais
pas dire ben il faut les dégommer ces
gens-là il faut les dégommer il faut les
en tout cas faut
politiquement
politiquement politiquement
politiquement oui ben bien sûr mais
peut-être même physiquement
électoralement
électoralement je vous en prie je vous
en prie je vous en prie ne disons pas
cela et je retire cette phrase que vous
n'avez pas pensé pour vous parce que
évidemment on ne peut pas aller sur ce
type d'injonction la France insoumise
qui n'a pas condamné le Hamas n'est pas
responsable des crimes pass sur le sol
en réagissant comme ça ils sont
complices alors euh derrière parcal pro
lui dit que les mots sont forts qui est
qui ne voudrait pas qu'il y ait des
problèmes mais Enrico assume regardez je
retire le mot que vous avez employé
d'abord que je voudrais pas j'ai
beaucoup d'affection pour vous et je ne
souhaiterais pas que vous deveniez la
cible précisément vous savez je vais
vous dire je je moi je dis ce que je
pense moi je n'ai pas peur d'être une
cible j'ai tout le temps été menacé
tout le temps et ben je n'ai pas peur je
n'ai pas peur je dis ce que je pense
devant cette horreur c'est tout alors
enenri comas merci merci Fran tapirot
spécialiste en communication politique
d'être avec nous est-ce que vous
comprenez les réactions de la France
insoumise Enrico mas il a quel âge il a
plus de 80 ans 84 84 Enrico moi je vais
dire après ce que j'en pense également
et vous avez vu la bienveillance de
Pascal avec vous ça vous bah je
comprends pas du tout les raction la
France insoumise alors moi je je vla
expliquer les réactions de la France
insoumise mais bon allez-y non mais en
gros la France insoumise c'est offusqué
de ses propos ils ont même annoncé pour
certains porter plainte contre lui
Jean-Luc menchon je crois parle de
menace de mort il a simplement donné son
avis il faut se poser la question de
quel côté se situe la violence est-ce
qu'elle se situe du côté des gens qui
soutiennent presque qui cautionnent
presque le terrorisme ou bien de celui
d'un homme qui donne simplement son avis
qui fait une sorte de cri du cœur et qui
évidemment ne pense pas au mots presse
qu'il a dit et là on reprend ses termes
on les manipule on pousse ses propos
encore plus loin pour le faire passer
pour le méchant donc évidemment non je
ne comprends pas ses réactions et je
trouve ça très noble de sa part d'avoir
assumé ses propos et de ne pas s'être
excusé de ne pas avoir voilà céd à ça
àion bah c'est l'inversion de la charge
accusatoire c'est-à-dire que au lieu de
se concentrer sur le vrai problème qui
est que le le ramas vient notamment
d'égorger 40 enfants des bébés des
femmes qu'a violé brûlé et je dis pas
tout parce que même les mots ne
traduisent pas la réalité de ce qui se
passe euh on vient s'en prendre un vieux
monsieur de 80 24 ans qui apprend ces
choses-là qui est frappé dans son cœur
dans son dans son âme et qui voilà don
dont les mots vont peut-être un peu loin
parce que effectivement il est pris par
l'émotion et et qui et qui au départ ou
dit oui effectivement politiquement et
puis après il dit physiquement et puis
après il comprend qu'il va qu'il va
qu'il va trop loin mais mais c'est c'est
juste un cri du cœur à un moment il faut
que on se rende compte qu'il s'agit d'un
d'un homme qui qui reçoit quelque chose
comme un cri du cœur et après pardon
mais quand je vois par exemple un tweet
d'Adrien catnins qui lui-même a été
accusé d'avoir frappé sa pro F qui vient
donner des leçons à enas j'ai envie de
lu dire Adrien
CATV c'est le chameau qui se moque du
boss il me semble que voilà voilàpr
après il y en a qui sort du quandme
c'est
franis il faut le dire voil voilà vous
vous êtes choqué jeux des gens choqués
également oui mais moi je suis
extrêmement choqué par ce qu'a dit enri
Maas enfin Valérie dégommé physiquement
même sil est r mais non mais c'est ça le
débat dégom physiquement dégommé
physiquement c'est une provocation au
crime je suis désolé réhensible c'est
condamnable là il dit carrément il faut
les éliminer bien entendu que sur le
bien entendu valrie je partage tout je
partage tout sur l'indignation des actes
barbares commis en Isra sur le même plan
c'est scandale ce que tu
fais par qui
parleuse-m excusez-moi je en fait ce qui
me sidère c'est même d'en faire un sujet
on parle d'en Matias le mant de l'amour
vous voulez en faire le m de la mort
vous attendez une PHAs sortie une phrase
bien sûr qu'elle est choquante cette
phrase qui l' dit dans quel contexte à
quel moment quel âge a-t-il c'est un
moment d'émotion pure de colère in
j'étais avec lui 10 minutes avantentrer
sur le plateau je vous parler écoutez ce
que je vais vous dire écoutez ce que je
vais vous dire il était ému au larmes
juste avant pourquoi parce qu'il en a
marre de voir cette espèce
d'agression exactement cette agression
incroyable où il a découvert ses enfants
décapité ces femmes décapité violé
laissez-moi aller au bout et donc il est
tellement il rentre sur le plateau et il
disent qu'il penseent à 84 ans avec
l'émotion et à 84 ans je vous souhaite
d'avoir ce genre d'émotion parce que on
compare une petite phrase de rien du
tout avec un parti la France indigne qui
ne reconnaît même pas le caractère
terroriste d'une attaque vous voulez que
je vous sorte les photos vous voulez que
je vous sorte les vidéos vous allez voir
que cette petite phrase qu'il a sorti
vous allez vite la ranger du côté de
votre tête pourquoi non mais non mais
attendez là on est en train de faire un
faux procès fa un
procèsne vous regardez vous t ceux qui
pensent I et à tous les spectateurs
pourquoi autant cette phrase pourrait
être chocante avec ve dire un adversaire
politique mais enriatias qui est un
homme d'émotion un homme qui était en
colère qui était au bord des larmes je
suis désolé mais ça vaut pas le coup de
lui en vouloir parce que d'abord
aujourd'hui ce dérapage il s'est excusé
alors que la France soumise n'a pas
dérapé ça a été écrit pensé assumé ils
n'ont pas voulu un reconnaître le
caractère antisémite terroriste il son
sont pas excusé donc on a hrico qui
s'excuse on a la secte mélanchoniste qui
ne s'excuse pas et vous mettez ça au
niveau de du scandale excusez-moi mais
c'est scandaleux ce que vous
faites pour moi vous êtes tombé comme
Unal dans le piège de la France comme
d'habitude tu tu tombes dans tous les
pièges si mais laisse-moi te parler
parce que tu es
tombé es tombé comme dans le piège de la
France insoumis et je vais t'exliquer
pourquoi la France insoumise ça fait
depuis des jours et des jours qu'ils en
prennent plein la gueule et à juste
titre ils se font dégommmer hein par
tout le monde et par la sphère politique
et par beaucoup de gens sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment après il y a des gens
qui sont d'accord avec eux aussi mais
juste qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait la
France insoumise ils sont dit mais c'est
une chance incroyable pour nous on va se
mettre sur ce pauvre Enrico Matias qui
va détourner l'attention de toutes les
horreurs qu'on a pas voulu justifier et
même avouer sur nos tweets ou sur nos
déclarations et ils sont dit bah on va
se mettre sur en comme ça on va
détourner l'attention et on va se faire
passer pour des victimes ils sont bien
plus malins que toi je te le dis donc
voilà donc c'est exactement ce qu'ils
ont voulu faire la France insoumise et
des personnes comme toi sont tombé les
deux pieds dedans voilà donc Enrico Maas
il a fait juste un truc qui peut être
pour moi qui le seul truc qui me fait
chier dans ce qu' fait Enrico mas pour
moi je vous le dis c'est que il a donné
du grain à moudre à la France c'est tout
le reste je vais te dire il a 84 ans
arrêé s'excuser derrière pour éteindre
toutes les polémiques suite à d'IER sur
ces news je n'appelle évidemment aucune
violence physique ses propos ont été
tenu maladroitement sous le coup de
l'émotion et de la colère suite à
l'attitude choquante de la France
insoumise qui refuse de qualifier le
terrorisme les attaques barbares
perpétré en Isra en Israël Enrico mas il
a 84 ans tu te rends compte ou pas il a
parlé il a il a parlé il a parlé avec
émotion on peut bien sûr que c'est pas
bien de dire ça mais tu crois quoi tu
crois qu'enricoomas il a préparé son
coup il était sur le plateau il était en
direct il a lâché ça voilà il a parlé
avec l'émotion et il a voir des images
juste avant et et voilà il est arrivé et
il a dégoupillé mais bon voilà c'est pas
pour ça qu'il faut lui faire un procès
le procès la France insoumise est
beaucoup plus important que le procès
d'Enrico mas excuse-moi donc toi et et
ceux qui disent oui c'est bon merci je
vais te dire ceux qui disent oui
excuse-moi je dire la vérité il bien sûr
qu'il a déconné Enrico je veux savoir
pourquoi vous dites oui d'ailleurs
Géraldine et et Hugo et et Delphin mais
les gars c'est il a fait juste un seul
truc il a il a apporté je te dis de
l'eau au moulin de la France insoumise
et ils sont dit tien tu quoi ils ont
voir ça hier on lu dit bon les mecs
c'est pas mal on a un petit truc là faut
aller à fond là-dessus on va gagner du
temps on va aller à fond là-dessus on va
passer pour des victimes pourquoi vous
dites ouiah précisément pour ça en fait
évidemment j'adore henricoassias on voit
bien que c'est une sortie viscérale
épidermique il suffoque en fait il y a
son cœur et son corps qui suffoque il
faut rappeler quand même que céit un
juif algérien qui a jamais pu repartir
retourner dans son pays parce qu'il a
été victime d'antisémitisme toute sa vie
et c'est une grande souffrance pour lui
en plus en plus Enrico je peux te dire
il est tellement pour la paix tellement
il a ch
é toute sa vie a chanté pour la p tu
crois quoi
en ça le déchire de voir ça comme nous
tous ça le déchire parce que il est il
est Enrico il est je te le dis je le
sais il est qu' est comme nous il dit on
est on est on est au milieu du truc et
c'est ça nous fait chier c'est tout et
je peux dire qu'il a parlé avec émotion
eten arrête arrête de faire comme ça
s'il te plaî arr vous faiteser pourquoi
je dis simpleement je réagis à dégommer
physiquement C c'est toutgommé
physiquement c'est
pas j'ai oui mais c'est c'est un petit
oui parce que bien évidemment que j'en
veux pas Enrico Matias et cétait un cri
du cœur mais c'est juste comme vous pour
ce que j'ai dit en fait fait c'est juste
que je sens un climat de de violence
générale et et ce qui se passe en France
aussi
m'inquiète la France c'est un pays
particulier c'est un pays particulier ce
conflit il a une résonance tout à fait
particulière en France particulièrement
donc moi les les jours qui viennent les
semaines qui viennent m'inquièteent et
je vais vous dire moi je pense pire
queco Maas sur la franceçise mais
j'essaie de rester cal parce que je veux
pas je
pas 84 ans ouais je je je je je ne veux
pas envenimer des choses qui qui qui
vont arriver des des des paroles sur les
réseaux sociaux à la télé j'ai envie de
mesurer parce que voilà moi je vais vous
dire j'ai je regrette il y a une chose
que je regarde dans ma vie c'est d'avoir
un jour mis un bulletin de vote France
insoumise c'est c'est un de mes P si
c'est c'est un de mes PIR regrets parce
que je me suis laissé avoir comme une bu
et là aujourd'hui je me dis mais
qu'est-ce que tu as été con ça très bien
je pense que aujourd'hui s'il y a une
personne où un groupe qui crée de la
violence en France c'est la France
indigne depuis le début comment imaginer
qu'un député qu'un homme politique ou
qu'une femme politique puisse se trouver
face à ces photos face à ses films face
à ces cris face à cette horreur et ne
pas être touché en tant qu'être humain
et non pas en tant que politique non pas
en tant que juif cez vraiment que la
religion donc aujourd'hui ceux qui
créent la violence physique verbal et
qui en venime et qui vont faire que
demain les futurs Mohamed mer et frèr
quachi se sentent protégés parce qu'ils
ont le blanin d'un parti qui a des
députés à l'Assemblée et qui ose dire ce
ne sont pas des terroristes ce sont des
résistants imaginez que je sois là ce
soir en vous disant mais vous savez ceux
qui ont flingué tout le monde au
Bataclan et l'yper cacher était des
résistants ce n'était pas des
terroristes imaginez la France a besoin
d'apaisement c'est exactement pour ça
qu'il faut parler deux il faut pas
parler d'IC mais il faut parler de la
France indigne je pense que la la France
insoumise le gros problème de la France
insoumise moi je v dire et c'est c'est
c'est c'est le gros problème c'est
l'ignorance on a eu Louis Boyard ici je
vais vous dire c'est pas le couteau le
plus éguisé du tiroir non mais c'est
vrai Louis Boyard c'est son seul fait
d'arme c'est d'avoir été dealer donc
voilà donc excusez-moi voilà donc Louis
Boyard voilà Louis Boyard et les autres
pour la plupart ils n'y connaissent rien
on a vu mathil Panau qui a été interrogé
elle elle est comme je vous dis moi à
l'oral du bac devant le tableau je ne
comprends rien et je sais pas quoi dire
et ben c'était mon mati de panneau
c'était ça elle quitte la salle elle
quitte la salle pour ne pas avoir à
répondre à répondre tout simplement sur
face à son blocage sur le fait de
considérer que c'est le ramasse son les
terroristes ne tomberz pas dans la Panou
merci oui Delphine pourquoi oui oui
parce que euh la France pour moi c'est
une cocotte minute qui risque d'exploser
à n'importe quel moment il y a beaucoup
de haine beaucoup de violence les gens
sont de plus en plus susceptibles et et
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui cette
guerre-là elle elle elle déchire les
gens et j'ai peur que certaines
personnes un peu fragiles pourraient
tomber effectivement dans ce panneau de
de la haine et aller physiquement
dégommer des gens pour pour pour le truc
de la religion CZ vraent qu' y a des
c'est pas parce qu'il a 84 ans parce que
vous le répétez souvent il a 84 ans mais
au bout d'un moment quand on passe à la
télé on est tous ég et notre voix porte
alors pas tous é alors est-ce que est-ce
qu'on dit qu'à 84 ans on peut encore
rouler en voiture ou on repasse le
permis par contre à la télé on repasse
pas un truc pour
savoir se disent on va aller tabasser
les gens de la France insoumis personne
ne s dit ça tout le monde a compris dire
mais PL moi je dire le seul le seul truc
que je vois verd je te le dis c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tout le
monde exactement se trouve au milieu au
milieu de ce confit voilà et qu'on a on
a pas envie de ça je vous le dis que ce
soit les bah oui tous les gens que je
croise ils ont pas envie de ça voilà et
aujourd'hui la France insoumise elle ne
fait catiser la haine sur les réseaux
sociaux et c'est eux qui sont
extrêmement présents sur les réseaux et
extrêmement actifs qui font sur les
réseaux sociaux il y a un embrasement
comme celui qu'il y a en ce moment et la
France insoumis je l'ai dit souvent
attention elle joue à un
jeuis un autre argument aussi pour ne
pas plomber Enrico et son image c'est
quoi c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils sont où
les Bedet ils sont où les stars ils sont
où les sportifs ils sont où les
musiciens les magiciens ils sont où les
comédiens alors laissez-moi vous
répondre dans un instant à ça je vais
vous répondre là-dessus je vais vous
répondre là-dessus parce que je vais je
vais je vais vous dire ce que ce que
j'en pense moi voilà de tous ces gens
parce que je vois plein de trucs euh
passer sur les réseaux aussi avec avec
des gens qui mettent des des des des
têtes d'artistes et qui disent ils sont
été portés disparus personne ne réagit
je vous dire ce que j'en pense dans un
instant on va en parler juste après à
tout de
suite